I'm not Money Motivated you know I don't
wake up and say I want money I don't
even carry cash I don't care about it
but I do know the significance of the
level that money holds and I know like
how you can help people with it my goal
is to be a billionaire before I'm 30.
it's extremely possible because it's
very possible I just gotta stay
disciplined I want to do it though so I
can help shape the world in a better
place you know I don't want to be the
billionaire that's dirtying up the world
I want to be the one that's like okay
let's create a meditation centers let's
create better prisons you know or
something like that not to like build
prisons but how do we change the prisons
how do we reform prisons things of the
nation like vegan food um anything that
revolves around my lifestyle
you